foreign
why do couples really fight about money
what what is going on here what do we
know yeah so this is interesting so this
came out from psychologytoday.com and it
says yeah I talked to anyone about their
relationships with their partners and
you'll discover that every couple has
disagreements so in an attempt to
identify the contents of financial
issues
uh I said this name I said that I think
the name wrong oh pizza is that what you
would say yeah yeah they did a study the
two studies conducted yep two study
study one they gathered descriptions of
fights about money from posts on Reddit
God God bless you uh from this large
pool of data they were able to identify
two overreaching themes when it came to
money arguments Ken one was concerns
about fairness number two was perceived
responsibilities and many of them
identified these issues falling into
under these two overreaching themes uh
they list some of more of the issues
down below and then they did a second
study where they gathered data a
financial conflict from couples in a
committed relationship and two
overarching themes happens in study too
concerns about fairness and
responsibility re-emerged and
additionally new con uh was mundane
expenses the conflict of that which was
related to disagreements about Minor
purchases such as how much money you
should spend on a birthday party oh 100
or yet who can pay for uh
yeah related expenses so care really
yeah no car related expenses so here's
the thing I identify with that one
because we joked about this I think last
time we were on the air I get a little
irritated at Stacy spending money on
like little gifts
um
I am a giver but women just find reasons
to buy gifts you know and so I remember
early on now it's not a big deal I'm
talking early on when we were really
trying to figure out sure I'm talking
early in marriage yes listen I said I've
been married 25 years I've long since
learned to let that go or I wouldn't be
married this long Okay so this was a
long time ago but I do remember that
like little things like well we're
spending this much on this little party
there's another one that got us when the
kids were little they get invited a
birthday party you're in the thick of
this now or you're getting in at least
the two girls are getting invited to
birthday parties all the time
consistently I'm an adventure to say
that both your girls get invited to five
to ten parties a year minimum sure true
story yes or that adds up oh yeah oh
yeah that's why I love Amazon because
you can get really cheap gifts yeah and
you have some good content on this on
Instagram I know because you could
easily he spends you know for these toys
that these kids want to kill us 50 bucks
easy no we're gonna lower that okay so
here's what's interesting about what
they found though Ken the first study
concerns about fairness and perceived
responsibility I think tell me if I'm
being naive if you can if if you had all
of your money together as a married
couple like we talk about
there's not technically fairness because
you're seeing it all together right it
doesn't matter who brings in the income
the amount of money that hits our count
is ours that's right and then perceived
responsibility we're all responsible for
all the bills together because we're
we're one it's actually perceived
irresponsibility and so and if you look
at this so what they're saying is you're
being irresponsible with debt you're
being irresponsible and planning these
were the things that came up that
created conflict so they were perceiving
that their spouse was irresponsible in
the areas of impulses of course gambling
broken promises and then under fairness
I pointed this one out terms of
Arrangements such as should we combine
finances a lot you know if you look at
another one under fairness
um contributions you know who's paying
these expenses and it's like that all
goes away right if you do what Ramsey
Solutions and what we believe which is
we're all on the same team it's not
together your money it's our money yes
yes so pretty interesting to responds
that say perceived responsibilities up
here or yeah
anyways well are you responsible or
irresponsible so what I'm saying is the
findings so not just specifically about
what bills you're responsible for that's
right it's more about are you
responsible or irresponsible in general
as it relates to debt budgeting but
here's the point the reason I point that
out is because a lot of tension there
when one of them this comes back to what
we our basic teaching is we begin to
move people through Financial Peace
University is the nerd or the spender
and so the idea is there can be tension
there because the the nerd the natural
saver thinks that you're being
irresponsible and you go slow your roll
but see you're not irresponsible I'm
just trying to live yep yeah 100 100
well what's interesting too about that
is I'm like even the nerd could actually
be the Spender
and like that's Mom and Dad Dad is the
nerd but he's way the spender my mom is
a little bit more of the free spirit
doesn't care about the budget but she's
the saver so you combine all these this
twisting of everything yeah and it's all
braided together fair in marriage and
having to figure it out so yeah I mean
but this is a big thing you guys because
under all of that is budgeting impulse
spending gambling broken promises
planning debt so all of that for the
most part overarching
can't I hate to say fixed because I know
it's just number quote unquote fix but
it can be this level that Yeah we
actually are way more on the same team
when you communicate you sit down and
you talk about it so all of that it's
just fascinating and then uh yep all of
the mundane expenses which is uh which I
tend to spend more money on so you take
that that's right but it's it's it's
really you nailed it there I mean that's
what the study finds that's where the
tension lies and and so to the extent
that you can go all right so uh
responsibility irresponsibility what I'm
feeling this is a conversation ago I
feel this because this is the way I'm
wired with money know yourself know your
money a fabulous book that you wrote
really does help unpack stuff like this
to know wait a second how I perceive
money may be very different than how my
spouse perceives money but that's
important to understand because that's
where tension arises a hundred percent
and going into those conversations you
guys with this is one thing I feel like
I've just learned over and over it's
humility like I feel like I know what's
right and I feel like I know it's good
but what if I don't know everything and
same with the spouse like if you both
come in and say yeah I I feel like I can
learn I want to learn I want to hear
what you have to say and you both come
in like that like that's a totally
different emotional take than I'm coming
in with what I want what I know is right
it's like these absolutes that I think
really get us in trouble Ken and there's
probably in so many other areas of
marriage but especially with money like
if you are the spender go in with the
saver with your spouse and be like hey
what are they feeling what like because
maybe they actually have wisdom going on
within them that I can learn from and
then Savor same thing like go to your
spender and say gosh what are areas of
me that probably need control uh have a
level of scarcity you know like these
things that could be negative on your
side what can you learn from your spouse
but that humility piece I think putting
the pride aside that's really good I
wrote down I wrote down four words just
looking at the study do they all have
the same beginning letter no they don't
oh man but it starts off that way I
wrote down same page same account I
think the key to not having a bunch of
big fights same page that means what do
we believe about debt what do we believe
about saving like are we on the sampling
page gambling right that's right are we
on the same page it doesn't does it mean
that we agree on everything but it means
we're on the same page Stacy and I have
realized this in parenting I know you
and Winston are in the middle of this
you're learning your parenting Styles
and as the kids get older the conflict
gets greater and your Styles come out
and it's
that we have learned that and I think
this is true of money
Stacy and I aren't always on the same
line
there's lots of lines on the page yep
but we are on the same page and I think
with money I think it's as complex as
parenting yeah there's a lot of stress
in parenting too and so I think if
you're on the same page we may always
only be on the exact same line the same
word but we agree this is where we are
on the same page and I think that allows
us to then go okay we do need to be on
the same account I'm still flabbergasted
Rachel by the amount of couples
that may be on the same page but still
have separate accounts and that creates
all kinds of weirdness all the time I
don't notice that you could truly be on
the same page if you have separate
accounts if you're paying for separate
bills to run one household that's just
weird to me yeah it doesn't help you get
on the same page for goals shared goals
a shared future so uh really interesting
stuff Rachel